un ciné c'est la première fois que tu
entres dans un confessionnal absolument
ça viendra clôturer tutoyer les ouailles
mais quel effet ça fait bizarre mais ça
manque de danse en deux cierges et c'est
pas très dansant non c'est un peu le
décor heureusement la peine de mort ou
aux comptes cours pour la peine de mort
pourquoi à pour éliminer vraiment il ya
des ordures qu'ils n'arrivent pas de
vivre pour les criminels de guerre les
assassins enfants peut-être pas ça
dépend des circonstances atténuantes et
ouvre enfin ses pages suis pas contre la
peine de mort a priori gestuelle et m
par exemple les prolos légende en herbe
des immigrés ces gens là leur tapent pas
dessus le recouvre un tas de
circonstances atténuantes gérant je ne
me moque pas d'eux dans les dessins est
ce que tu crois en dieu
non je n'ai jamais cru en dieu non c'est
jamais effleuré n'ont jamais un maire
n'a fait baptiser m'a baptisé je sais
pas comment ça s'appelle en travaux
depuis terminé que parfaite communion
jamais entre les ans sauf pour admirer
qu'architecture non je parle comme je ne
sens pas concerné dit si tu me crois
qu'il est en enfer ou paradis
je crois qu'il fait par les asticots
frais d'épicerie la chasse ne pas croire
cette manche jamais su que je me disant
du pô le métier croit sort de la merde
facile en quoi il faut que gbagbo
donc c'est plus facile de croire
monsieur je crois beaucoup d'entre eux
n'est pas radieux et corrections de ne
rien rater de in a l'habitude abonnez
vous mettez un pouce bleus